hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in Hegel's famous dialectic of master
and slave that we find in the self
consciousness portion of his great work
the phenomenology of spirit Hegel first
sketches out the position of the master
what it is that is going on on the side
of the master what what he or she is
attempting to attain and how that
connects with not just the slave but
also the world of things there's a lot
of mediations occurring a lot of
connections in just these three short
paragraphs 192 192 and if we think about
where the Lord or master came from Hegel
says that originally there's some sort
of struggle to the death right to self
consciousnesses and the slave gives in
because they're too attached to their
bare life and the the Lord or master
then takes over now we could imagine as
indeed many other commentators have
situations that are not quite so primal
is that where one person is in the up
position and the other person is forced
into the down position throughout
culture history time you know extending
into the future that's all interesting
what we want to do here is look exactly
at what Hegel is sketching out and then
see if we can apply it in those sort of
cases so he starts off by talking about
the Lord as being a consciousness that
exists for itself and he says something
has been achieved here something stable
he said it's a consciousness existing
for itself mediated with itself through
another consciousness through the
consciousness not of other masters but
of the slave the Lord knows who and what
he or she is precisely by the existence
and the activity of the slave and that
is an activity that is not just you know
the slave doing something for the master
in a pure ISIL
dyad rather the slave is connected with
the entire world of things this could be
as trivial as the slave is the one who
always has to make coffee and bring the
coffee in and get the order right about
how many creamers sugars go in it and
make sure that the you know wooden stick
is there or a spoon if you prefer that
instead or you know things as elaborate
as you know vast caste systems with
clearly defined you know you're working
on this you're working on this you're
working on this and you're never going
to get out of that and everything in
between so Hegel says that the Lord puts
himself into relation with both of these
moments the the other consciousness and
to the thing hood in general so the the
Lord er master puts him or herself in
relation to the world of things through
desire we have desire for all sorts of
things desire big-eared a-- is something
that's basic to self consciousness for
Hegel and and much of that desire is for
things like eating and drinking and
enjoying creature comforts of all sorts
and building things and you know going
from place to place all of these can fit
into that and the Lord or the master is
the one who's been able to do that why
because it's not just their own work
indeed it's not going to be any of their
own work in a moment that is
accomplishing it but the work of the
slave the slave is set to labor on the
independent world so I mean just
consider for an example this book itself
how many different processes and for us
industrial processes had to go into
making this forget about having you know
Hegel write it just think about the
sheer sets of activities and how many
people were involved in creating the
paper let alone the binding and the ink
that that's involved and then
typesetting it all of that is is
somebody working on the external world
the Lord doesn't really do much of that
that's what's nice about being the lord
of the master you
other people do all that that as we call
grunt work you know the work for the
peons you know whatever other ways we
want to talk about it you know in our
own day we might say that the Lord could
be in you know corporation there the
people say I'm an ideas person I don't
actually do all the work involved I come
up with the ideas and that all of you do
it you know nowadays largely through
subcontractors so Hinkle says that the
this master puts himself in relation
with the thing and such through desire
and the consciousness the consciousness
of the slave so the plane has an
interesting you know duality here I'm
the one here on the slave has to be a
consciousness or else they can't be a
slave on the other hand they're being
treated also as a thing a thing that
works on other things
so Hegel goes on and he says that you
know there's a mediation that that's
occurring in this case the Lord is able
to have the desires for this world of
things met by the slave engaging in
labor the slave has to subject him or
herself to the independent world it's
not a lot of fun and they work upon
things and by working upon things they
transform them into then products which
can be enjoyed by the Lord
Hegel will tell us in this section that
the Lord takes the dependent aspect of
the thing and enjoys it and consumes it
whereas the slave takes the independent
aspect the part that resists us the part
that makes us have to work at it the
part that requires us to subordinate
ourselves to get up at certain times to
you know work our fingers to the bones
make our hands bleed all all these sorts
of things so the Lord gets what seems to
be the good part of the product the
thing right and the slaves gets the
crappy part the part that people don't
want to have
at the very same time something else is
going on here because the desire that
the Lord has is not simply for having a
cushy life you know filled with as we
said lots of creature comforts and as we
say sitting on our laurels right the
Lord or master is also interested even
more in another kind of desire desire
for recognition on our Kennan in Hegel's
German from the slave and he attains
this recognition in part by being over
the slave and making the slave satisfy
his or her desires giving them the
things taking the the the best parts of
it for him or herself so why does the
Lord get to do this Hegel tells us well
the Lord is the power over the thing he
proved in the struggle to the death that
he it is something mere you know merely
negative he has power over this thing
and power over the other person and he
holds the other in subjection now if we
go on Hegel tells us that in so then
both of these moments the Lord achieves
his recognition through another
consciousness the other consciousness is
expressly something uh nacelle this is
going to lead us to another paradox both
by working on the thing and by its
dependence on a specific existence and
neither case can it be lord over the
being of the thing and achieve absolute
negation of it the slave is in a doubly
bad condition on the one hand the slave
is subjected to the independent world of
objects that he or she has to work on
that the Lord or master doesn't want to
hear about they they're not interested
in you know how many hours the slave
needs to work in order to make this
happen or in the you know craftsmen like
or perhaps later industrial processes
except insofar as the Lord decides to be
concerned with that maybe if they want
to manage their estate well the slave is
kind of
in a lonely position on his or her own
working in a world of objects that he or
she is set to transform which resists
him or her at the same time there's
there's another thing the slave is
dependent upon the Lord for or the
master for their very existence and
their existence sucks it's not a good
existence it's a totally dependent one
down position to be it as we say so
Hegel talks about this as leading to an
interesting dynamic he says the Masters
essential nature is to exist only for
himself he's the shear negative power
for whom the thing is nothing he is the
pure essential action in this
relationship that of the slave is impure
and uh nacelle what does this do to
recognition can you really get
recognition in the sense that you're
looking for it as the master from the
slave Hegel says no for for recognition
proper the moment is lacking what the
Lord does to the other he also does to
himself and what the bondsman or slave
does to himself he should also do to the
other so Hegel says the outcome of this
is a recognition that is one-sided and
unequal the master is not able to attain
the kind of recognition that he or she
was actually desiring from the slave
precisely because the slave is a slave
and it's set to work on all of these
objects and is dependent upon the master
for his or her life so he says in this
recognition the unofficial consciousness
is is for the master the object which
constitutes the truth of a certainty of
himself but this object doesn't
correspond to its notion there's there's
a disconnect here between the reality
and the ideal and it says the object in
which the Lord has achieved his lordship
has turned out to be something quite
different from an independent
consciousness you can only get
recognition that you truly desire from
another independent consciousness the
slave however is a dependent
consciousness so what is the outcome
when Hegel has been talking about is the
Lord you know or the master having
certainty of self through this
recognition now he finds out that the
truth of this certainty is that he's not
really attaining it the truth winds up
being something perhaps painful now of
course there's ways to get around this
you know lose yourself and enjoyment
lose yourself in the sheer sense of
power but Hegel thinks that there's
something actually empty and unfulfilled
in the existence of the Lord
you